bien souvent très suivi aujourd'hui on
se trompe pointe petite compilation de
jeux sur tablette on commence tout de
suite avec qt incruste menu avec stick
est rehaussée parti qui est un jeu assez
drôle dans lequel on fait grandir son
véritable pénis voilà exactement comme
ça il le fait très bien
ah voilà par exemple moi c'était bien
nul allez à bientôt et quand enfin
perfect c'est con mais la barque pile
sur le maintenons nos bateaux mais il
passait pas dans ce petit trou on va pas
chercher des excuses à temps à me moquer
le moins de minuscules trous tout se
pète la gueule non je veux pas partagé
qui ne me forcez pas des dons à ok il
faut remonter tambay et patronat fois la
seconde s'il vous plaît vous allez trop
loin
ah ah bah voilà non mais j'ai fait mes
relais aux [ __ ] sa cb schikaneder à
temps mais c'est super ils font rien ils
sont très drôles à aller voir la
perfecta c'est nous qui sommes
maintenant au nom mais merde mais c'est
sérieux ce genre de choses et je parle
avec une voix aiguë mais pas les costa
mesa mais c'est pas possible mais cette
folie mais des petites plaques hop là ça
va mieux
hoste et limitant comme on dit dans le
milieu qu'il n'a pas de limites tombe
dans le vide un quoi mais du coup je me
concentre pour prendre les cerises et je
suis pas faire deux choses à la fois
voilà je lave ou alors le cliché de
l'homme qui s'est pas fait les choses à
la fois c'est complètement vrai sur moi
la beauté du jeu m'éblouit and real
engine iv voyez ce que la lah ont fait
défaut les [ __ ] mais comment mais
c'est trop proche de l'estrie est une
école pas conomie en bordel tu l'écueil
coller à l'air mais ce que je veux dire
n'est ce pas non c'est bon [ __ ] on a
battu notre record mais qu aux arrêts
sur image est ce qu'on se fout de notre
gueule
oui il ya des choses qui me kim kim
outre voilà samut comme une outre sa
sainteté par la française aussi un
médaillable a lâché loutre à la lune
elle porte bonheur voyez moi j'adore
vraiment la pleine lune j'ai fait que là
j'ai fait un score de malades voilà
allez salut aulas micropénis aulas
moyens penny ou au micro ils sont bien
foutus de notre gueule pour nous laisser
croire qu'on était forts pour finalement
tomber sur sa annonce au nom mais non
non je veux plus à quoi servent ces
cerises allait justement à tout de suite
parce que je pète un câble et à savaria
as pour débloquer un héros commence un
peu acheté des cerises mais vous avez
pas honte bordel bon je vais pouvoir le
deuxième personne
oui je sais tape les jours c'est un bon
combat
j'y croyais pas que dans le pays
attendait là c'est le mans il nous
laisse croire que et voilà mais là on
leur montre qu'on est plus forts qu'eux
au non non non non non non non mais non
mais non mais ferme toi [ __ ] mais
jusqu'au bout on a les jeux suivants bah
tiens c'est très bien ça c'est un très
bon jeu au comme c'est rigolo
on est maintenant sur zigzag vous avez
conseillé se joue aussi sur une fois je
n'ai absolument rien vu je crois que ça
joue que l'uja tablette ou pas c'est
quoi alors c'est juste un hacker a je
comprends je comprends la diction et
voilà et je comprends la rage mais ils
font plus en plus compte des besoins
plus efficace comment ils sont doués ces
gens qui font des jeux vraiment par
contre c'est pas assez dur je trouverais
ça manque un peu difficulté moi je suis
déçu je ne peux être que déçu devant
l'ampleur deux jeunes vaches un bagel
bros wii et on a vraiment sous les yeux
le jeu le plus simple du monde en terme
de gameplay et où quoi et puis jamais
dans une vidéo je dirais le terme en
terme à aaa avec un battant mais
l'allemand bruit avec cet escalier en
zigzag assez long du jeu y'a pas de
souci non ils sont dus en lassons pas la
peine
voilà à la place de m as on va faire en
sorte que le décor d'air lui s'effondre
puis voilà le taf effet là je parle mais
j'ai envie de jouer toute la journée
bordel allez on va faire un petit mil
quoi attendre mais la boule elle est ce
pas plutôt ya des trappes ya des pièges
on les a pas pu c'est ça ah ok c'est que
le contraste entre le plus foncé qu'à
présente le vide il est passé où faut
des buts serge jeu d'ombrés vraiment ce
tricheur ce jeudi voila voila c'est
tellement choquant que même la boule a
fait j'arrête
en fait j'avais retiré le sont ah oui
bon finalement voilà la différence est
belle et pas trop présente
apparemment ils ont fait appel à david
guetta pour faire la leçon de ce jeu
donc il a fait 200 paul et c'était parti
quoi mais ils sont bien faits par contre
c'est du symbole de qualité un vraiment
c'est l'inflammation non pas des prix
mais des chutes
monsieur mambé dessus en faisant cette
expression lui le haut et du coup je
perds je me promets zigs et des zags et
je m'en vais un et le dernier jeu de
cette sélection et mouzin je veux mais
qu'on sait sur twitter moon bellance
moustapha envie super digestion moose
jaw mode gestion dans le titre semble
avait pas vendu comme ça donc bon je
suis pas fier de vous vraiment m'avait
dit mousse tout court table tout plat il
c'est parti et alors qu'est ce que j'ai
à faire je vais lui envoyer la
nourriture c'est ça oui tu m'écris oui
mais voilà il a mangé allez mange
et pas qu'à 4 mai à temps mais justin
mais c'est assez clair tu manges il faut
de la galerie un score de 3 6 nuls
j'ai même source que sur fley bieber ou
alors que l adie de la différence de
difficultés présentes et pourquoi j'aime
pas dire être bagué de mes phrases
bordel à la carotte qu'elle est belle au
le lymphome elle est belle non mais mon
ipad soit mon ipad est cassée soyez un
problème je pense le problème c'est moi
si je suis nul à tous les jeux tout là
bas et là elle put à regarder
des fois il n'a pas envie de manger à ce
qu il fait caca et il a du mal à s'en
sortir la la il est maigre pour une
durée indéterminée ailleurs en cdi
maigreur
attention c'est bon il a pris non wipro
ça cette chose envie de faire caca du
coup il ne mange plus il fait son kacou
mai salle vide complètement immer [ __ ]
mais incroyable quoi allez mange
regardez des fois il n'a pas envie de
manger c'est ainsi qu'au dessus c'est
moi qui lui fait caca et sur la tête
quoi grosses menaces attention aux
menaces de d'enfants et ce1 voilà avec
les copains qui rigole d'ailleurs pas ce
qui est mon cas dans la phrase j'ai
trouvé un jeu auquel je suis encore plus
nul que sur géométrie d'âge bordel sud
est béni oui oui monsieur
oui mais le champi ce nul la pomme jeu
mais qu'est-ce-qui au revoir n'en a
peut-être qu'un truc qui digère pas
genre les champignons non si il se dira
pas les champignons voilà si bien le
comprendre au bout de 22 minutes je
pense que tous ceux qui le savent et
devait m'insulte non non pas de
championnat sont pas choqués mais par
quoi
ah bah voilà tout de suite ça a beaucoup
mieux allez allez allez la nourriture
s'il vous plaît non non non et ben voilà
le high score et mios est pareil je
faisais mes infos bieber bordel il est
bien la regarder j'aime bien voir c'est
prolonge une des seules personnes que
j'aime bien voir engraisser à mort comme
ça will à port louis la deuxième au mont
houy la k1 merde
elle m'a carottes allez rigoler aux
blagues acheter nous rigole manche
non non je mets mon doigt sur ton cul
pour empêcher ce qui ressort à assez
rigolo les blagues sur le pipi kacou 1
alala autant au combat le record ou pas
non non
on a fait du kung fu avec ses bruitages
alors qu'en bas je suis qu'une merde je
fais du ping pong mais bon c'est bien
comme ce soir mais je pense que paris
contre mike fait du karaté parts on ne
fait pas long feu
voilà et si on retourne et un peu sur ce
jeu et qu'on parlait de sa part
enveloppe [ __ ] pourquoi ce chantier à
la gueule d'une pomme bordel une pomme à
la varicelle une pomme coccinelle à
champignons finalement bordel on y
révèle l'ampleur non non ça dégage salut
mercredi 11 février
c'est sa wild wild west et non pas comme
ça merde j'en ai marre de voir cette
crotte de 20 m à paraître sur mon [ __ ]
d'écran ou citron c'est bon pour
l'agencé ria oui ça oui c'est bien toi
tout ça on découvre des trucs c'est la
photo cela tombe au nom oui oh là là
heureusement que mon ipad n'a pas été
bien appuyé sur le champix à marange
c'est bien je frime qui caresse après
montblanc panerai voilà j'ai tout raté
au moins gardant au nom mais du coup on
se souvient de la caresse j'en ai marre
de ce match au pub et a7 et ruelles
sales têtes de merde c'est drôle comme
je sors ça bizarre allez salut j'ai pas
de vie 26 bordel et c'est sur ça qu'on
termine cette petite compilation de jeux
j'espère c'est nous on a plus fait
pourquoi je saute c'est cannes et cpm et
vidéo comme d'habitude merci d'avoir
regardé une vidéo très vite dans une
nouvelle se retrouvent
oui c'était j'ai mis vingt minutes à
préparer à dire cette phrase ok alors
respectez moi [ __ ] mais surtout au pis
elle j'ai une répartie pour lucas
a bizarrement tabid est là
[Musique]